pas le temps voir le pas plus large
garde garde aux plus larges
regarde toi regarde à ta gauche regarde
ces îles blanche doit verte au milieu de
tout ça vachement beau tout ça tu vois
voilà mes films et ville méchas et c'est
parti ben un peu toi là dedans avec les
petites îles qui est au milieu
alors ta caméra le padduc aux côtés un
mois je me verrais plutôt à gauche voit
par là la voilà partie de la gauche voit
plus à gauche encore plus à gauche
encore à gauche encore à gauche encore
encore assurée bien voilà six piles que
tu vois tu vois ces petites bêtes bien
en vertical qui voit bien les passes
verticales pas tous et pas en basse et
ses petits trucs vachement beau tout ça
tu vois beaucoup de tous les chemins des
hippopotames puisqu'ils sont à ta droite
tu vas tu ressens vachement beau jeu
c'est super beau ça toi devant doute à
plein de chemin d'hippopotames pas bon
genre de temps passes tu à ses bonnes
habitudes il faut pas avoir peur de
faire des erreurs et houari peau
pas de revenir un peu sport tas
d'obstacles aux jeux pour toutes et
toutes les îles bref un rendez vous un
été où d'où on vient à la 4e place
little bit et nuria gorrite super
artiste vous m'appelez 23 sep excuse moi
donc quand élus devancent les mots et
c'était assez gossard pas se pencher
trop vite
ok devant voilà au soleil et où je vois
peu plus à droite des voix la vache
propose aux barbes et cette petite
blanche inquiète rebelles devant toi
donne un peu de mouvements à tout ça
enfin oui la boule la laitue ne prête
pas savoir où va un peu sur agout vago
jouer à gauche à gauche doucement à
gauche dans le soleil de barre à gauche
à gauche à gauche tu vas passer à gauche
en contre jour c'est sublime
quand je vois la vase ou le remplacement
rock là dedans à gauche sur la rampe
l'odeur âcre aux comptes carrément dans
la voiture à tout en excusant ac voulait
pas qu'ils oublient écarte un peu moisie
rentrent dedans m'attends à gauche voilà
revint à gauche par de larges marges
l'argent là-dedans relatives à ce propos
ce défi de planches à la pulp et de
zoomer sur les petites îles qui sera
apte à gauche si tu veux ok witter rêve
de larges et rivaux aussi larges lames
d'argent était ok là dehors de tapas et
sur le saut edf va revenir sur le large
tout à l'heure par la pluie la lame est
juste le vrai ce très beau ça va les
atteindre de nouveau à droite de sa
toiture
moi j'irai en comptant aussi lutter
contre les dangers des zooms
complètement des zooms complètement
alors d outreau bêtement devant
l'appareil voilà on va rechercher en
vertical voilà en fait ça le rock et le
jeudi un supplément verticale corbières
il ya un côté blanc seau pas trop
éclatée
dès que tu peux garder du contrat sur
les deux avec la caméra mais si on peut
garder du contrat sur les deux à monza
assurent les deux ok ok tout
voilà si tu veux sortir de leur masse ça
suffit c'est bon pour nous à passer le
grand ville blanche ans et moins
intéressant peu de vent juste derrière
des le club pater intéressante popotin
derrière tu peux vous voilà on va
revenir raté tout à l'heure on va passer
par la gauche mais on peut toujours être
ok pour toujours à tous avec cherche
dans son vin en allons pas par areva au
mont fricotter délictueux de shadow joe
biden briquet et couper un squat à
couper un jour est ce qu'ils ont mais
ils vont aller à bâtir et se trouvait à
bel est bien plus tard au printemps
après au poids du couple vit on est un
couple plein de couleurs ne coupez pas
danser canal est d'instaurer le truc on
vallon du [ __ ] on voit on voit dans les
bras c'est pas grave on s'en sert pas
les parties
ok mais après
plus bas prix sur des voitures et on n'a
jamais cru de charger plus par magie un
jésuite patrie d'un bon repas pris dans
mon sac à l'arrière objets avec l'écran
je réponds ça que par la place
aux archives
on avait ça très vite à
vaussard macho sabour a perdu le soleil
la meilleure peugeot se redire écarter
un peu peut-être à tapas sérère mon avis
dans le coin de l'image plutôt peut-être
sauvé y voit les jolis nes et là bas à
12h puis quoi joli là c'est dans le hall
a vendu en fourbe
on va se on va enfin arriver dessus avec
des antilopes l'année passée un mouchoir
gars derrière moi à quatre pattes et le
cros de croquer d'art aubade al adab
ibbi
je préférerais que ce soit devant pad en
contre-jour mètres devant la caméra sur
la rivière bleue et poussa alors ombre
attention voilà ça c'est sous la rivière
rouge en revanche de la voie bleue on ne
comprend pas pour rien ou tu es devant
par derrière avant
je n'ai appel à vous
brad park d'art
je le revois encore pour moi et face aux
bucks du cap et aux touristes vous
inspire
espada commis un faux fichier daf est
soit chic gardien d'oise ou juste à côté
on rails basé sur un plat
alors moi je souhaitais un peu large la
tour en jarez info palun fois des champs
mais j'aurai moi j'aurais été un peu
plus la plus large toit j'aurais été
plus jolie qu'on a fait le plus paysage
autour coup là puissent avoir le paysage
en entier toi de voir le bras de rivière
noire avec ceux qui ont la leur vie
entière ont pu compter sur un bon
j'aurais fait ça toi sont ce pas
passionnant donc la rivière en entier
tout voilà le bon peuple entier on va le
découvrir dans en valeur enfin possible
arrivée entre cody le passé dessus tout
1 1
on passe vite on le doit au smat very
pique pas que jolis toi j'ai les bras le
corps entier là on le voit pas si tu le
vois je vois dans l'image de classe du
bassiste eu envie pour le sistan vivre
sans toi
bazoum dessus at war furent bien le voir
la finale passionnante leçon à l'écart
et s'en va sous loué par pouce en l'air
comme c'est beau non oui mais voilà il
par ipad blanc ok péniche